[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo cette semaine émission
spéciale présidentielle en france avec
marine le pen dakota emmanuel macron de
l'autre une présidentielle qui
s'apparente plus à un référendum pour ou
contre l'europe
alors pour en débattre sur ce plateau
philippe juvin bonsoir vous êtes aux
députés français du groupe ppe à l'est
républicain en france pour cette
présidentielle vous avez soutenu la
candidature de françois fillon merci
d'être venu face avoue marie christine
vergiat bonjour vous êtes eurodéputée
française de la gauche unitaire
européenne
en france vous avez été élu sous les
couleurs du front de gauche
vous avez soutenu pour cette
présidentielle jean luc mélenchon merci
d'être venus enfin marc tarabella vous
êtes eurodéputés socialistes belges mais
pour cette présidentielle vous aviez
aussi votre candidat c'était benoît
hamon alors d'abord avant de voir notre
premier sujet une réaction tous vos
candidats ont été éliminés
vous avez été surpris philippe gil a
surpris je ne sais pas déçu évidemment
le vrai sujet c'est que il ya quatre
candidats qui ont fait aux alentours de
25% et donc l'élection c'est avant tout
une très grande fracture de la france
donc deux sont sélectionnés parce que
c'est le mode de scrutin mais on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui y compris le favori
qu'emmanuel macro ne recueille pas un
attachement formidable les gens vont
voter par des fois cette élection marie
christine vergiat vous aviez soutenu
jean luc mélenchon vous allez mettre un
bulletin macron dans l'urne dimanche
prochain oui tout à fait mais ça
mériterait quelques explications parce
que moi je comprends beaucoup de la
colère d'un certain nombre de gens je ne
suis pas tout à fait dans la même
situation qu'eux mais de mes deux
collègues puisque jean luc mélenchon a
considérablement augmenté son score par
rapport à la dernière présidentielle
et ce n'est pas un parti classique un
parti de gouvernement comme on dit un
parti gestionnaire il n'est pas des
représentants d'un mouvement la france
mise
et il a séduit de très nombreux
électeurs alors c'est vrai c'est vrai
que la france est partagée
mais la leçon de ce scrutin la première
leçon de ce scrutin pour moi c'est que
les partis classiques ont été éliminés
de la constitution et ça pose un
problème en termes de démocratie
et ça pose un problème en termes de
démocratie notamment par rapport à la
question européenne mais je pense que
nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir
marc tarabella si vous étiez français
voter pour qui sans hésitation dimanche
prochain je voterai pour monsieur macro
évidemment parce que il représente aussi
les valeurs démocratiques face à un
risque je dire de dérive au niveau de
démocratie creuse entre marine le pen
ferment j'étais aussi déçu par le score
de benoît hamon qui n'apportera pas
démérité qui a été un candidat qui a
clairement ancré le parti socialiste sur
des valeurs de gauche sur un vrai
programme de gauche et bon ben il est
victime lui aussi du vote utile qui fait
que dans les derniers dernières
encablures à un moment ses partisans
certains ont rejoint au fado dévots du
parti socialiste ont rejoint monsieur
macron peut-être prématurément et
d'autres ont voté utile qui se sentaient
à gauche mais qui voulait qu'à espérer
avoir un candidat de gauche au deuxième
tour et ont voté
mélenchon est donc celle a été victime
un peu de ce système à deux tours qui a
ses mérites mais qui a aussi ses
faiblesses
alors samedi dernier c'était le dernier
sommet européen françois hollande à
bruxelles samedi dernier pour son
dernier dernier sommet européen françois
hollande a fait le bilan de son action
est mise en garde contre la montée des
populismes on regarde et on réagit juste
après
c'est son dernier sommet européen
la démarche est solennel on prend le
temps de saluer ses homologues à c'est
l'heure du bilan aussi ici en cinq ans
françois hollande aura dû gérer des
crises crise financière crise grecque
crise des migrants le break cite
justement ce jour là les vingt-sept ont
adopté à l'unanimité leur stratégie
vis-à-vis du break site les réelles
négociations commenceront après le 8
juin et s'annonce difficile
alors quand la présidentielle française
prend des allures de référendum pour ou
contre l'europe
françois hollande en profite pour se
livrer à un plaidoyer pro union est le
choix qui posait pour le dimanche 7 mai
c'est de savoir si les français n'ont
pas simplement globalement mais
individuellement ont à craindre d'une
sortie de l'union européenne ils ont
tout à gagner à rester dans l'union
européenne de ce point de vue c'est vrai
que l'élection du 7 mai c'est un choix
européen l'occasion aussi d'avertir sur
le saut dans l'inconnu que constituerait
l'élection de marine le pen à la tête de
l'état et de mettre en garde sur les
populistes printemps qu'il continue de
le penser
continue de le prévoir continues de 2 le
de préparer ce projet dangereux de
sortie de la france de la zone euro et
de l'union européenne
il le camoufle il le ils le cachent ils
le gomme parce qu'ils savent bien que
les français ne veulent pas que leur
pays sorte de l'union et faut surtout
éviter écarté un risque majeur qui
serait la présence de l'extrême droite à
la présidence de la république
françois hollande quitte le conseil
européen avec le sentiment du travail
accompli
même si son action a souvent été
critiqué pour son manque d'ambition
européenne le 22 juin pour le prochain
conseil européen
ce ne sera pas lui mais son successeur
qui représentera la france au sommet de
bruxelles
[Musique]
alors question toute simple quel bilan
vous faites de ce quinquennat
hollande au niveau européen il est plus
bas non mais c'est quand même une vaste
rigolade pardon ça serait une ça serait
une rigolade si ce n'était pas la france
et l'europe en jeu le président de la
république françois hollande est
incapable de se représenter tellement
son bilan est catastrophique un chômage
de masse alors que nos voisins vaut
mieux une croissance dont on ne parle
pas des délocalisations à tout va un
sentiment pro-européen qui est en berne
en france est finalement une montée des
extrêmes et il dit ah j'ai le sentiment
d'avoir bien travaillé avec les qu'est
ce que ça serait s'il avait le sentiment
d'avoir mal travaillé
il n'est pas capable de se représenter
parce que son bilan est mauvais y
compris en termes européen on voit bien
qu un effacement total de la france donc
il
ils se désespèrent de la montée des
extrêmes et des populismes celle mots
qu'ils utilisent je crois mais il l'est
un des responsables de la montée de ce
populisme devant un échec flagrant
internes et externes parce qu'en réalité
les échecs internes sont aussi des
échecs européens dans un monde marié
marc tarabella un bilan si négatif de
françois hollande au niveau européen je
n'ai pas la même analyse que philippe
duval ne surprendra pas à françois
hollande dans la monette
il a mis l'intérêt de son pays et voir
de sa famille politique au dessus sur
l'intérêt personnel françois fillon on
aurait dû faire autant et la famille de
droite républicaine serait peut-être
dans une autre posture aujourd'hui dans
une situation clairement il a il a bien
vu que se présentant à la présidence
république il aurait été battue parce
que les sondages défavorables
je pense que son bilan ne sera pas si
négatif a posteriori que ce qu'on veut
bien dire aujourd'hui au niveau là on
attendait plus d'audace le cern ont tué
le de jacques delors soudaine mois une
réussite une réussite
lefrançois une série site européenne il
est clair que c'est de ce point tu là
qu'il m'a le plus déçu je le dis aussi
d'un point de vue européen j'attendais
un contre-pouvoir de gauche face à
vannes à merkel est la toute puissance
de la famille parti populaire européen
qui aujourd'hui et pour le dumping
social en europe encourage les
délocalisations je m'excuse mais quand
on veut voter concours des lois plus
régulatrice hausse au niveau européen
moi je me trouve très sonné comme un
verger à le front de gauche et
écologistes contre la famille de
monsieur jules 20 contre les gens les
construire
remis au parlement la droite mais on
parle de dealers ne veut pas régulé ne
veut pas lutter contre le dumping social
ne veut pas une harmonisation fiscale ce
droit des sociétés en europe
ils ne le veulent pas et donc
aujourd'hui c'est facile de se lamenter
d'un bilan qui est mitigé certes et qui
au niveau européen effectivement est
décevant parce qu'il ya eu de
contre-pouvoir par rapport à la droite
européenne
que symbolise vallat merkel tout
puissant n'en est pas une seule règle
marie christine vergiat sur françois
hollande son bilan il va marquer
l'histoire européenne apparemment sol
anglais lourdement responsable de la
situation actuelle
françois hollande il lourdement
responsable de cette situation
cette situation parce qu'il avait fait
des promesses en matière
en matière européenne notamment la
renégociation du pacte budgétaire est
immédiatement et lui il a fait
exactement le contraire il est venu à
bruxelles
et il s'est tu contrairement à ce qu'il
a essayé de de raconter donc il a une
lourde responsabilité
il a une lourde responsabilité sur la
désespérance d'un certain nombre de gens
et sur le fait qu'un certain nombre de
gens considèrent aujourd'hui que droite
et gauche finalement c'est tout pareil
et malheureusement un des problèmes qui
nous est posée dimanche c'est d'avoir
comme alternative à l'extrême droite
monsieur gilles van hamme extrême droite
c'est monsieur macro qui est dans la
droite ligne la continuité des
politiques de françois hollande
donc moi je dis à mes amis
politique à ceux qui ont voté pour jean
luc mélenchon il faut choisir entre la
peste et le choléra
et je sais que ça provoque des réactions
je sais qu'ils sont furieux je comprends
leur colère que vous choisissez le
général emmanuel macron c'est ça je
comprends bien je choisis le choléra
lorsque je pense que par rapport au
choléra y un vaccin
je pense que par rapport au choléra il
peut y avoir des mobilisations et il y a
aussi les élections législatives qui
arrive parce que nous savons que
monsieur mac on continuera le second
tour on élimine et 4 heures on a des
après on se bat on se bat alors quel
programme les programmes sur l'europe
pour les deux candidats marine le pen
emmanuel macron preuve que l'europe est
un enjeu majeur de cette élection
présidentielle on a vu l'affrontement
emmanuel macron marine le pen à amiens
sur le site de whirlpool a qui doit être
délocalisée et emmanuel macron s'est
fait interpeller sur les salaires en
pologne puisque c'est en pologne que l'
usine doit être délocalisée le point
avec radhika
[Musique]
marine le pen et emmanuel macron sur le
même terrain tous les deux en visite
chez whirlpool a bien le fabricant
américain va délocaliser sa production
en pologne 600 emplois sont menacés
je n'ai pas promis que j'allais
nationalité blanc le pool que j'allais
interdire leur licenciement parce que ça
n'est pas vrai et je leur ai dit je vous
garantirez des conditions dignes
je me battrai pour la reprise du site le
programme des manuels macro ne comporte
pas de mesures spécifiques sur les
délocalisations
en revanche marine le pen entend taxer à
hauteur de 35 % les produits des
entreprises délocalisées derrière ce
conflit
deux visions de l'europe aux antipodes
s'affrontent avec la défiance croissante
vis-à-vis de l'europe depuis le
référendum de 2005
marine le pen l'a mis au centre des
débats elle prône ainsi une sortie de
l'union européenne et le retour au franc
emmanuel macron entend lui renforcer la
gouvernance au sein de la zone euro en
lui donnant un budget un parlement et un
ministre de l'économie le fondateur dans
marche se veut le candidat de l'europe
non ces meetings on brandit fièrement
que le drapeau européen
ce même drapeau que marine le pen a
demandé de retirer lors d'un passage sur
un plateau de télévision pour le fn
l'europe est la cause du chômage ou
encore des problèmes de sécurité
marine le pen veut fermer les frontières
pour selon elle empêcher les terroristes
de frapper sur le territoire national
elle entend donc rejoint les accords de
schengen pour en finir avec la libre
circulation des biens et des personnes
nos détracteurs nous disent qu'en
voulant retrouver nos comptes hier nous
allons nous replier enfermé le pays sur
lui-même
mais quelle fariboles si n'importe quoi
comme pour votre maison une porte ne
vous enferme pas à l'intérieur
elle s'ouvre si vous le voulez pour
entrer ou sortir elle sourd si vous le
voulez pour faire entrer vos invités ou
leur permettre de sortir après les avoir
reçus marine le pen a toujours pour
objectif la sortie de l'union européenne
et le retour au franc
même si depuis son alliance avec nicolas
dupont aignan elle affirme ne plus en
faire un préalable
emmanuel macron fustige ce programme
qu'il qualifie de mensonges et est ce
que nous pouvons aujourd'hui sortie de
l'europe et de l'euro
je le dis non seulement à vous aux
salariés qui doute à ceux qui ont peur
ce camp dont la défendons la surtout il
espère lutter contre la montée des
discours anti europe et propose la tenue
de conférences citoyennes pour proposer
un nouveau projet européen l'europe a
les yeux rivés sur le résultat de cette
élection
l'un des candidats inquiète les
capitales européennes et les marchés
alors que l'autre rassure nos voisins
européens
[Musique]
alors question toute simple que
répondent aux salariés de whirlpool
amiens le smic polonais c'est trois fois
moins que le smic française c'est vrai
que c'est dur de résister oui qu'est-ce
qu'il faut répondre a clairement nous
disons que l'europe souffre de ceux de
ces différences trop importante et
aujourd'hui faut-il essayer de les
diminuer
on leur n'égalera pas évidemment si vous
proposez d'égaliser tous les salaires en
europe le grand patronat souhaitera
qu'on travaille au niveau de la roumanie
salariale la roumanie qui est douze fois
moins important que le salaire en
vigueur au grand duché luxembourg la
moyenne plus élevés
clairement ce qu'il faut soit pas il
faut être attentif c'est d'éviter de
tomber dans le piège que thomas ram à
marine le pen elle est habile
elle a une grande qualité elle est
habile et rusé parce que faire ce qu'il
dit ce serait catastrophique pour la
france parce que ce serait une fermeture
on vide nos exportations également est
donc clairement ce qu'il faut évidemment
c'est revoir la directive se cachant les
travailleurs qui est en train qu'ils
soient table du parlement aussi de faire
en sorte que quand un travailleur
notamment par rapport au secteur
notamment de la construction qui est le
plus impacté comme celui du nettoyage
comme celui même des soins maintenant
aux personnes c'est de faire en sorte
que le salaire qui est payé à la
personne qui travaille à un endroit les
lois sociales y afférentes et l'impôt
soit également payé au tarif du pays
dans laquelle le prestation la
prestation se fait c'est pas gagné ici
hein parce qu'effectivement on se heurte
à un groupe de droite généralement qui
n'aime pas cette règle qui pensent que
le marché intérieur
c'est une compétition et qui veut faire
pression sur une moindre protection
sociale c'est fondamental 2
nous avions proposé à quelques années au
sein de mon groupe 2
en sorte que quand une entreprise se
délocaliser au sein de l'union
européenne si elle a reçu des aides à
saint pourçain salé ou des avantages
fiscaux
elles doivent les rembourser là encore
dans la commission économique qui s'y
opposent
toute la droite européenne donc il faut
savoir qu'un mandat ni à les combats que
l'on mène ici pour que l'europe soit
plus comestibles plus protectrice des
citoyens et qu' il y a une majorité
malheureusement encore aujourd'hui qui
n'entend pas ce type d'argument philippe
juvin c'est la droite qui bloque
l'europe sociale dans mes jambes plus
comestibles je veux bien qu'on soit
responsable de tout mais dans ce débat
du second tour
au fond vous avez abordé dans votre
reportage l'essentiel pourquoi quelqu'un
membres des républicains comme moi homme
de droite je vais finalement voté macron
je vais voter macro parce que je vous ai
pas posé la question le choix de marine
le pen est un choix qui va créer le
chaos
la sortie de l'union la sortie de l'euro
la remise en cause des équilibres
tout ça fait que l'économie française
sera la première à souffrir de cette
isolationnisme alors elle vous explique
avec son affaire de la porte qu'on ouvre
on ferme enfin pardon mais aujourd'hui
les sociétés françaises vendent dans
l'union européenne c'est le premier
marché des pme françaises les pme
européennes nous vendent aussi des
matériaux qui nous permettent de nous
mêmes de fabriquer et de revendre et
donc fermer les frontières françaises
c'est en réalité appauvrir complètement
l'économie française et donc moi je suis
macro nist d'une manière très ponctuelle
dimanche moi parce que je ne peux pas
faire autrement
est-ce que vous bloquez ce que la droite
bloque ici au parlement européen une
réforme de la directive travailleurs
d'algérie sûr que non au contraire nous
nous pensons que la directive doit être
vue très profondément pourquoi parce
qu'il ne doit pas y avoir de dumping
social ni salariales entre les états or
aujourd'hui il ya un dumping social et
salarial
une fois qu'on est ce que c'est la même
faute de l'europe alors d'avoir d'avoir
trompé largy par dale est parallèle mais
une fois qu'on a dit ça on n'a rien dit
parce que c'est comment on y arrive
effectivement marc tarabella rappelé que
les écarts de salaires sont elles dans
les états que dire y'a qu'à homogénéiser
tout ça et bien c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui comme ça ce n'est pas
possible
donc ce que nous proposons simplement
c'est d'y arriver progressivement et
d'un côté vous avez marre
le pancake qui elle est en train de dire
si on le fait immédiatement soit en sort
on peut pas le faire immédiatement et
vous avez macron qui justement dans ces
affaires-là ne prend pas position
et c'est un des éléments qui nous gênent
considérablement avec macro c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on est à quatre jours de
l'élection c'est parce qu'ils pensent
sur tous ces sujets il n'en a pas parlé
c'est quand même ahurissant marie
christine vergiat ces délocalisations
aussi qui fait mal à l'europe
aujourd'hui bien sûr que c'est ça qui
fait mal parce que l'europe telle
qu'elle est construite aujourd'hui c'est
du tuning social organisé et on ferme
les yeux sur les petits jeux de la
pologne et du groupe devise rade en
particulier on va délocaliser vire paul
en pologne et l'espagne et qui on va
embaucher dans ces entreprises en
pologne des salariés polonais nom des
salariés ukrainien il y à un million
cinq cent mille ukrainiens qui sont
arrivés sur le territoire polonais en ce
moment parce qu'il a eu il soit encore
moins payés que les salariés polonais et
les salariés polonais pendant ce temps
ils viennent faire du dumping social sur
l'europe de l'ouest c'est un nivellement
par le bas simplement l'échec de
l'élargissement c'est celui là quand la
grèce l'espagne et le portugal sont
rentrés dans l'union européenne on a
fait des politiques de convergence
économique et social c'est d'ailleurs
intéressant de se rendre compte que la
fameuse directive travailleurs détachés
elle a été adoptée à ce moment là pour
éviter la concurrence entre les oui
aujourd'hui on ferme les yeux sur ces
réalités là et on met en concurrence non
seulement les salariés européens entre
eux et les salariés européens et serein
des salariés de l'union européenne et
ceux des pays voisins et madame madame
le pen aux nous dire il faut ouvrir ou
fermer la porte elle la ferme
systématiquement quand est-ce qu'elle a
dénoncé ce qui se passait avec les
ukrainiens elle qu'elle soit disant
contre l'immigration à tout va c'est une
mine l'immigration économique qui équipe
actuellement conduite 1 1 million 500
mille cinq cent mille ukrainien qui
rentrent chaque année avec des visas des
visas de travail pour l'essentiel en
pologne on n'en parle jamais on n'en
parle jamais on ne parle que de ceux qui
paient qui me rend en méditerranée on
instrumentalise cette question alors moi
je suis pour qu'on discute de toutes les
questions qu'on mette laver
idée des chiffres et qu'on arrête de
traiter cette question en faisant appel
aux peurs et pro-européen b a commencé
en fait je ne fais pas peur je demande
qu'ils soient traités de la même façon
moi je demande qu'on battrait madame le
pen quand vous dites ça pardon quand
vous lisez moi et arrêtez vos
caricatures monsieur jiva si vous voulez
je vous respecte donc en vous et 2014
à la frontière de la pologne c'est
dangereux je n'ai jamais dit ça pardon
je n'ai pas dit que c'était dangereux
c'est vous qui mettez ces mots là ce ne
sont pas mais c'est mon là c'est un
constat c'est une réalité on
instrumentalise les migrations
économiques mais on dit il faut arrêter
les migrations économiques
1 il ne faut pas ouvrir les voies
légales pour les migrants et les
réfugiés
moi je dis exactement le contraire il
faut que l'on cesse de laisser les gens
mourir en méditerranée comme ces codes
comme c'est le cas actuellement
tarabella boulianne avec sa wii parce
que niveau européen quand on dit la doua
de la gauche je veux pas être
caricatural non plus moi j'ai beaucoup
travaillé que philippe juvin sous la
directive marchés publics et concessions
c'est quelqu'un avec qui on peut parler
et donc j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
les gaullistes rang c'est parce qu'ils
ont le sens de l'état l'autorité
publique moi je l'appelle
si monsieur macron gagne comme on peut
l'espérer ici autour de la table c'est
qu'à un moment donné il ya un
ressaisissement au niveau européen et
qu'ils puissent y contribuer lui avec
peut-être marqué les choses en face de
lui en allemagne on sait pas si c'est
madame merkel il faudra taper du poing
sur la table et faire en sorte que
l'europe devienne plus supportable pour
tout le monde et faire en sorte que l'on
on essaie de limiter ces inégalités et
qu'on fasse en sorte qu'on du marché
intérieur qui nous a apporté beaucoup de
bienfaits
mais aujourd'hui il est dérégulé
notamment sur le plan du travail c'est
qu'on puisse apporter des régulations
nécessaires etc abandonné qu'on soit de
gauche socialiste ou pas socialiste
qu'on soit de droite républicain en
france et je dirais dans d'autres pays
c'est qu'on arrête de laisser la voie
ouverte aux ultralibéraux
moi je combats pas le libéralisme le
libéralisme il faut le réguler parce que
le capitalisme n'est pas vertueux par
lui-même il faut l'autorité publique qui
redistribue notamment par l'impôt par
une harmonisation sur l'impôt des
sociétés par exemple parce que s'ils
déménagent en pologne c'est peut-être
parce qu'à pas n'importe société lui
maria muniz et absolue mais donc ça
c'est fondamental c'est un combat que
nous pouvons mener ensemble
donc moi je crois à l'heure
parce que sortir de l'europe ce serait
une catastrophe et pour la france et
pour l'union européenne mais demain il
faut rester dans l'europe mais il faut
il faut redresser l'europe et la
redirige d une europe qui à nouveau
protège ce citoyen sortir de l'europe et
sortir de l'euro comme le proposera un
marine le pen enfin très son nom en
termes strictement juridique
sortir de l'euro c'est sortir de
l'europe pour des raisons qu'on ne va
pas expliquer ici qui sont un peu long à
expliquer dont la question est simple
l'europe actuelle elle n'est pas
parfaite et je partage un certain nombre
de choses qu'on décèle maintes reprises
il elle n'est pas parfaite mais
l'absence d'europe c'est encore pire
c'est ça le sujet est aujourd'hui marine
le pen propose aux français l'absence
d'europe
la disparition de l'europe elle d une
autre europe en réalité elle veut sortir
et si vous me permettez moi ya cette
très belle phrase de raymond aron qui
résume tout le choix cornélien des
français qui comme moi sont des gens de
bonne volonté et comme d'autres aussi
sur ce plateau c'est que dimanche
en fait on va avoir le choix entre deux
personnes qu'on ne voudrait pas et que
disait aaron et disait le choix en
politique ce n'est pas entre le bien et
le mal
et monsieur macro n'est pas le bien
pardon et mme le pen n'est pas le mal
pardon et arrow design préférable que le
préférable et le détestable et c'est ça
le sujet c'est que eh bien nous allons
être quelques uns à voter macron alors
même que nous pensons qu'il a bien des
défauts ce jeune homme se guerre parce
que si vous voulez que quelques-uns ça
va être terrible
il faut il faut effectivement mobilisés
on en veut beaucoup à l'europe mais
quand on regarde la situation de la
france par rapport à la moyenne
les pays de la zone euro 1 c'est plus de
dette publique en déficit commercial de
bass dans la série
merci sarkozy comme notre pack en fait
c'est plus un problème français mais
évidemment ce que de la zone euro et
vidéos évidemment non mais on dit judy
un certain nombre de gens madame le pen
dit c'est à cause de l'euro c'est à
cause de l'europe
expliquez moi dans ces cas là pourquoi
d'autres pays qui sont dans l'euro et
qui sont dans l'europe n'ont pas les
mêmes problèmes que nous pourquoi nous
avons un chômage de masse et pourquoi
nos voisins sont sortis de la crise
c'est ça le suggère il est d'abord
question est d'abord de choix nationaux
français les choix nationaux français ne
sont pas de bons choix et pardon
monsieur hollande après ses cinq ans à
nous a pas beaucoup aidé et monsieur
macron je le rappelle a été quand même
le miz et l'économie de monsieur
hollande qu'on le veuille ou non
allez on termine avec notre rubrique de
fact checking à le budget de l'union
européenne
thil en déficit c'est ce que bernard
mono le monsieur économie du front
national a dit à la radio vrai faux
c'est checkpoint préparé par thomas
millions
le budget de l'union européenne est-il
en déficit c'est ce que bernard mono
stratégiste économique du front national
a laissé entendre la semaine dernière
sur france inter aujourd'hui vous le
savez peut-être pas mais il ya un
déficit de l'union européenne depuis 25
ans depuis 220 milliards d'euros de
déficit de la balance le pardon du
déficit de l'union européenne dans le
but biais de l'union européenne est-il
réellement en déficit
pour le savoir il suffit de regarder les
recettes et les dépenses de l'union
européenne
que ce soit en 2015 en 2003 et même en
on le voit le montant des dépenses ne
dépassent jamais celui des recettes le
budget est maîtrisée par l'union des
états membres qui l'ont adopté il n'y a
donc pas de déficit
mais alors à quoi correspondent les 220
milliards cité par bernard mono et bien
il semble qu'ils fassent référence ce
qu'on appelle le ra elle le reste a
liquidé
c'est la différence entre les
engagements pris par l'union et ce
qu'elle doit encore payer pour les
honorer ainsi si des fonds européens
sont promis pour aider par exemple à la
construction d'un pont en slovaquie
l'union européenne ne transférera cet
argent qu après vérification de
l'avancée des travaux
ces démarches peuvent prendre du temps
mais elles sont nécessaires et en
attendant c'est font rentrer dans le
reste a liquidé côté chiffres le fameux
air à elle était effectivement de 217
milliards d'euros en 2015
il était même de 222 milliards d'euros
deux ans plus tôt mais peut-on pour
autant parler de déficit
les fonds prévus pour ses engagements
d'aidé budgété parlera donc davantage
d'un retard de paiement que d'un déficit
peut-on que ce n'est pas pour autant une
bonne chose pour la cour des comptes
européenne face à cette accumulation
d'impayés il deviendra de plus en plus
d'un jour respecté ses engagements dans
le cadre budgétaire en tout cas y at il
un des fils de l'union européenne depuis
220 milliards d'euros pas du tout donc
c'est faux voulu réagir
je veux réagir pourquoi parce que c'est
le spécialiste économique de marine le
pen qui vous racontent que nous sommes
enfin que l'union est en déficit or
c'est faux
donc voyez la bande de branquignols qui
souhaitent être élu dimanche c'est
absolument ahurissant un spécialiste
économique dans mon dieu il faut qu'il
retourne à ses études dans la caravelle
a très rapidement je partageais s'il
m'en dire un mot il ya 21 ans françois
mitterrand en avance avant propose
prononcé un discours au parlement
européen en tant que président du
conseil en 3 il a dit à la fin de ce
disque de nationalisme c'est la guerre
et se livrer la guerre
faisons attention à ne pas jouer aka
démocratie avec le feu
clairement je pense que l'europe a des
défauts elle a beaucoup de qualités mais
elle a des défauts il faudra la
redresser mais ce n'est pas avec des
extrémistes on y arrivera il sort sur la
peur des gens pour arriver à leurs fins
sont habiles à essayer de séduire les
citoyens franchement pense qu'il faut
avec une force démocratique essai de
rebalancer l'europe pour l'intérêt de
ses citoyens et j'espère que emmanuel
macron sera le président de la
république qui pourra remettre l'europe
sur les rails marie christine vergiat le
mot de la fin je pense que c'est
typiquement le langage de l'extrême
droite et du populisme en général de
faire le de mentir en permanence de
trafiquer les chiffres on le voit là sur
l'union européenne moi je travaille
beaucoup sur les questions migratoires
ce qui expliquait ce que je disais tout
à l'heure sur la question de crânienne
ils font exactement la même chose il
alimente les peurs 1 et c'est ça que je
combats - militants des droits de
l'homme - militants anti fascistes pour
moi c'est une priorité que de battre
l'extrême droite est de combattre ces
idées mortifère ce sera le mot de la fin
merci à vous trois quand même d'être
venus débattre et merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis c'est la fin d'europe de la
semaine prochaine pour trouver nos
ramadi bonne suite des programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires et la rtbf
[Musique]
e